now to politics and prose bookstore in
Washington DC for discussion of
Catherine Graham's Washington you'll
hear from Robert Gottlieb Evelyn small
Ben Bradley sally quinn and Michael
Beschloss it's an hour
I'm Barbara Meade I'm one of the owners
of politics and prose and I want to
welcome all of you here tonight to hear
six speakers talk about Katherine
Graham's Washington each in their own
way was very close to her I'm also
reminded that it was only about 18
months ago that we had a panel here Ford
made green fields book on Washington and
we had Don Graham we had Michael
Beschloss we had Jim and Kate lair and
we also also had Katherine Graham she
was obviously the star of the show and
that she had been very very important to
make Graham Greenfield and you'll see
and the people who talked this evening
how that she was able to work with
people in a very very friendly way and
bring out the best in them and if the
memories that they have of that are very
very special I'm first going to
introduce Bob Gottlieb who is the editor
at Knopf who worked with Katharine
Graham on personal history and then
worked with her
up until the time of her death and then
continued to work with F small who was
Catherine Graham's right-hand woman
there's no way to appreciate the amount
of work that she put into this book so
we're going to start with Bob Gottlieb
and he'll introduce the succeeding
panelists thanks
hi am I here Obul audible whatever the
word is uh okay so I thought I'd say
just a few words although I've also said
it inside the book briefly about how
this book came into being and why you
know anyone who knew Kay knew what a
worker she was and Kay Grey and without
occupation was not a happy carryin so
when personal history of course it took
many years to get it right and then it
was published and that was exciting and
the Pulitzer and the paperback and she
was very busy and very content with all
of that and then it was time to do
something else and she didn't know for
sure what she wanted to do so the idea
of another book came up and slowly over
a period of time through discussions
among k-f and myself we all came to
believe that the most useful and happy
book she could do would be an anthology
but not just any kind of anthology what
I had recognized through my endless
talks with her over many years was that
one of the great passions of her life
was Washington DC I mean I don't know
anyone who talks about his or her city
with the love that she always
demonstrated when she spoke of her town
that combined with another of her great
passions which people named out may not
be so aware of which was her love of
books her house was just crammed with
books there were books everywhere when I
stayed there which I often did or
usually did any bedroom I was in was
filled with books from head from top to
bottom and indeed when we were working
on this book that was very useful
because at midnight I would be
clambering up shelves and plucking down
volumes but she was very well read in
the Washington literature and she really
enjoyed it and this idea finally really
sparked her and we got to work on it and
she started writing introductions
general introductions introductions to
each of the pieces and writers as we
came upon them and over a period of long
period of time this book started to take
shape and when she died it was really
quite
close to completion the selections had
all been made a lot of the organization
had taken place and that was never going
to be what she was going to do and a lot
of the writing was done a lot of it was
completed some of it existed in the form
of notes that she had made scrolled
unpaid things she had said to have
things EV had picked up from discussions
and put in her computer from letters
from a great deal of research that went
into personal history but that never got
into personal history from her mother's
Diaries which have never been published
etc so our job was to organize it edit
it and issue it and you know she may not
have agreed with every decision we made
although the decisions were basically
made but I can at least tell you that
she would not have argued with the
editing because she didn't argue with
editing she liked being edited and I
can't think of anything in the first in
personal history where she objected to
cuts
she loved cuts she didn't really wasn't
very happy but when I cut many pages
about the Brandt Commission which I very
tactfully told her was among the most
boring material I had ever read but I
said it tactfully and then when Meg read
the manuscript she wrote in this in the
manuscript one paragraph at most but the
great thing about diagram is that she
told this story on herself wherever she
promoted the book and laughed that
wonderful laugh so anyway it was a labor
of love as I said the other day
somewhere her love for Washington and
our love for her I hope everyone who
reads it will understand that and feel
it okay so here's what we're going to do
four people are going to read selections
from the book the first is EV small
herself the power under beneath and
sometimes above the throne and she is
going to read a very brief selection
from Kay's introduction to the book this
was the first thing that came out when
we got underway she wanted to get it
clear in her head what the book was how
she was approaching it and I wanted you
all to have something of her voice
tonight since this is her night I I'm
gonna read just a very short part of the
forward because I think it's important
that you have a lot of time to to ask
questions of this group up here which
knows a lot about Washington but also
because I lost my voice about a week ago
I normally don't have such a sexy low
raspy voice but I will do my best in
this first part I wish that mrs. Graham
were here to read it because those of
you who ever heard her she had an
incredibly mellifluous if I've used that
word correctly or pronounced it
correctly voice and I would love to hear
her read this myself for more than eight
decades Washington has been my home town
my whole orientation is toward this
place it is a city that offers me more
people more different kinds of people
than I could otherwise possibly have
come to know in a lifetime the native
Washingtonian the local merchants the
foreign diplomat the ever-present
tourists the public servant the
journalists the president the friend it
is a city whose geography is embedded in
my mind the sidewalks on which I skated
to and from school through the cool
shade created by arching branches of
overhanging trees the streets on which
the twofold trolley cars and buses took
me back and forth to work the houses
great and small in which dramas play
themselves out publicly and privately
all the places to which I was always
ready to go it is a city whose industry
first and foremost politics both local
and national got into my blood early and
stayed there the arguments generated by
all sides of any given question the
intense issues that sparked countless
actions and reactions the gossip created
and contributed to by memorable
characters the events around which
swirled high hopes and rich dreams the
presidents who have both molded and been
molded by all that happens here in short
in Washington I've always found people
to see places to go things to do
although I was born in New York City my
parents moved to Washington in the fall
of 1917 just a few months after my birth
I'm not sure why I was the only one of
the five children in our family for whom
Washington became home all of us grew up
here for the most part although my older
siblings did go to school in New York
before my parents made a more permanent
move here but once each went away to
college no one but me came back I came
home again and remained here always
Washington held me I cannot imagine
living anywhere else
I love the Virginia countryside where my
husband Phil and I bought an old place
in the early 1950s Isle of Martha's
Vineyard where I have had a house for 30
years I have loved visiting countries
around the world but I always come home
to Washington in the very first entry in
my mother's diary her mother kept a
diary by the way from the time she moved
here in 1917 until 1933 when mrs.
Graham's father bought the Washington
Post a great diary in the very first
entry in my mother's diary back in 1917
she wrote the march of events has been
much too rapid that simple sentence
holds true for the entirety of my life
as well I believe that the fast pace was
exacerbated by living in Washington and
by all the drama that that involved from
my mother
this statement seems more of a lament
than something to cheer about for me it
has always been only the latter one of
the happy results of my backward glance
at the city that I loved is that despite
all the changes it reminds me of some of
what lasts in Washington of
what indoors including society civility
great men and women and some colorful
Rascals and devotion respect and good
work one of the most interesting and
amusing books I found while looking into
the city's past was a journal kept by
Ellen Maurice Layden wife of a Texas
congressman from 1897 to 1919 and
published in 1962 as Washington wife
just an aside she did indeed love this
book so much that she would constantly
read out paragraphs from it and I think
would have been very happy to have just
reprinted that book so be sure to take a
look at that one mrs. Slade ins wise and
witty commentary never ceases to amaze
and stimulate me and one of her journal
entries she wrote quote I am so glad to
have spent my life largely where the
figures and events of history stir the
Dulles scene as in Washington which if
it has little history behind is at least
engaged in the daily manufacture of more
this could easily have been a sentence
from the pages of mother's diary or from
the pages of most of the books excerpted
here the sentiment so true of that long
ago Washington remains true of the
Washington of today what fun I've had
with these bits of this historical
record of sorts of a time long gone
people long forgotten or miss remembered
and a place Washington where the march
of events continues at it's much too
rapid pace leaving ever more history
behind it and still engaging and making
more each day
okay next reading from her own piece
that is in this book sally quinn
intrepid reporter novelist star and Miss
adorable here she is I have to say I was
absolutely stunned and amazed when Bob
Gottlieb called to say that Kay had
chosen a peace of mind for her book
because I had no idea and I was really
honored that she did the piece which was
printed in April of 2001 was called why
do they hate Washington and actually Kay
was the inspiration for this piece
because she and I had talked about it
she was really upset that people when
they ran for office always ran against
Washington and created the impression
that we were just nothing but a bunch of
scoundrels and fools and knaves and
cheats and liars and thieves and and so
I decided that I would sort of do a
piece and try to figure out what it was
that made people turn against Washington
and run against Washington and I'm going
to read the beginning and the end and
then a little snippet in between I'll
try to make it as cohesive as I can my
zip code is 7/8 701 that's Austin Texas
it's not Washington DC if you were to
call me on the telephone it would be
area code five one two not 202 I am NOT
of the Washington scene I am NOT a
chairman of a powerful committee like
the Commerce Committee I come from
outside Washington DC that was George W
Bush mid campaign January of 2000
today his zip code is 200 500 his area
code is 202 and here's what he had to
say about Washington in February of 2001
no one can speak in this capital and not
be awed by its history and when we walk
through statuary hall and see those men
and women of marble we're reminded of
their courage and achievement if we work
together we can prove that public
service is noble though this was George
W Bush speaking it could have been
Andrew Jackson or Ronald Reagan Jimmy
Carter or Bill Clinton to hear them tell
it when they're running Washington DC is
the real evil empire it is Sodom and
Gomorrah the source of corruption and
scandal and big money and elitism and
everything that is wrong with our
country and yet they will spend two
years of their lives and hundreds of
millions of dollars to get here why so
they can change Washington of course
they can tame the beast they can make it
kinder gentler more civil more
bipartisan more productive more
compassionate more fair nobler and
result in most cases they become part of
the very culture they have been
excoriating in 1994 Republican George
Nethercutt of Washington State defeated
the Speaker of the House Tom Foley who
had served 30 years in Congress neither
cuts campaign theme was that Foley had
lost contact with the real people we
don't need a speaker we need a listener
was his slogan it worked
Foley understands why he remembers
listening to a constituent an ironworker
discussed his views on the life of a
congressman in Washington at a focus
group in 1994 asked what he thought
dinner would be like at the home of a
congressman he responded that he would
be picked up by an enormous limousine
taken to a huge mansion in Georgetown
seated at a fancy table with silverware
he didn't know how to use and served
food he didn't know how to eat all I
could think of chuckled Foley was the
humble basement apartment I lived in
while I was flying back in for
in my district every weekend the mere
phase inside-the-beltway makes people
hyperventilate K Street the symbolic
home of the lobbyist is anathema the
hill conjures up images of corrupt
congressmen taking paper bags full of
money Georgetown is the impenetrable
bastion of the elitist and now even the
White House is synonymous with scandal
and vulgarity enter at your own risk
fail to turn your back on it when you
leave and you turn into a pillar of salt
but stand on a hill in Arlington
National Cemetery and look down across
the Potomac to the Lincoln and Jefferson
memorials the Washington Monument and
the Capitol symbols of all that is noble
in Washington look past the graves of
those who have sacrificed so much to
protect these very institutions that so
many now revile has Washington changed
so much from those first I adil
idealistic and abused when those who
founded the city had such great hopes
for it apparently most Americans think
so in a 1998 Washington Post poll only
33 percent of Americans said they
trusted their government according to
the famous historian Michael Beschloss
this reaction is not a bad thing in a
way he says the criticism of Washington
is extremely healthy because the idea of
Thomas Jefferson was that to make the
system work Americans always had to be
in a state of semi revolution against
the government he would have been
terrified to think that in 2001
Americans might be uncritical of
Washington and let it steal their
liberties Tom Foley tells about a North
Carolina congressman who would come to
Washington only to vote he didn't want
to do anything he didn't want anything
to do with the city Foley said he had a
sense of contagion that this was a pest
hole of bad values and evil
interest if he left town he was less
likely to catch this terrible plague to
be brought down by the atmosphere that
he was less likely to end up in a huge
mansion in Georgetown offering his
constituents food they didn't know how
to eat and following Sally Quinn as he
often does we have Ben Bradlee I
believed it's something that the
Washington Post for some years I'm a New
Yorker so I'm unclear about these things
just let me say instead of reading his
own piece which he chose not to do
because of his extreme modesty he is he
is going to read something that seemed
particularly appropriate this week which
is as you all know the anniversary of
the assassination of President Kennedy
and this is from a piece by Arthur
Schlessinger in Catherine's words
introducing this piece all too soon it
was over the thousand days of the
Kennedy presidency passed too quickly
this was yet another ending for which
none of us was prepared again it was an
ending that didn't happen in Washington
only the pageantry that followed in the
next few days took place here we were
all so stricken that there was among our
circle of friends a sense of paralysis
this was just after just over three
months after Phil's death and I felt
traumatized again and numbed in a
different way
I wondered how it ever be possible to
find the right words to say to Jackie at
the time of Phil's death she had written
me a letter that I still hold dear and
there was such a comfort to me at the
time I could not imagine how she would
begin to deal with her new life I've
always been moved by authors rendering
of these sad days as he wrote and as I
remember so well it all ended as it
began in the cold and authors view
his piece on this comes from a thousand
days on Friday morning I had flown to
New York with Katherine Graham Kaif it
is all through this piece whose husband
Philip had died three months before for
a luncheon with the editors of her
magazine Newsweek Ken Galbraith had come
down from Cambridge for the occasion we
were still sipping drinks before
luncheon in an amiable mood of Friday
before the harvard-yale game relaxation
when a young man in shirtsleeves entered
the room and said a little tentatively
I'm sorry to break in but I think you
should know that the president has been
shot in the head in Texas for a flash
one thought this was some sort of
ghastly office joke then we knew it
could not be and huddled desperately
around the nearest television everything
was confused and appalling the minutes
dragged along incomprehensible bulletins
came from the hospital
suddenly an insane surge of conviction
flowed through me I felt that the man
who had survived the Solomon Islands and
so much illness in agony who so loved
life embodied it enhanced it could not
possibly die now he would escape the
shadow as he had before and almost
immediately we received the irrevocable
word in a few moments Galbraith and I
were on Catherine Graham's plane bound
for washing Washington it was the
saddest journey of one's life bitterness
shame anguish disbelief emptiness
mingled inextricably in one's mind when
I stumbled almost blindly into the East
Wing the first person I encountered was
Franklin D Roosevelt jr. in a short time
I went with Mike White House colleagues
to Andrews field to await the return of
Air Force one from Texas a small crowd
was waiting in the dusk McNamara stunned
and silent Harriman Haggard and suddenly
looking very old desolation everywhere
later I went back to the White House to
await the last return around in 4:00 in
the morning the casket route wrapped in
a flag was brought from the Naval
Hospital and placed on a stand in the
East Room tapers whirl it around the
in a priest said a few words then
Jacqueline approached the beer knelt for
a moment and buried a head in the flag
soon she walked away the rest of us
waited for a little while in the Great
Hall we were beyond consolation but we
were we clung to the comradeship he had
given us finally just before daybreak we
bleakly dispersed into the mild night we
did not grieve alone sorrow engulfed
America in the world at Harvard the
bells tolled in Memorial Church a girl
wept hysterically in Widener Library a
student slammed a tree and again and
again with his fist Negroes warned and a
Phillip Randolph said that his place in
history will be next to Abraham Lincoln
Pablo Casals mused that he had seen many
great and terrible events in his
lifetime the Dreyfus case the
assassination of Gandhi but in recent
history and I'm thinking of my own
lifetime there has never been a tragedy
that has brought so much sadness and
grief to as many people as this for a
time we felt the country was ours said
Norman Mailer's now it's theirs again
many were surprised by the intensity of
the loss alistair cooke spoke of this
sudden discovery that he was more
familiar than we knew is there some
principle of nature as richard
hofstadter which ins that we never know
the quality of what we had until it is
gone around the land people set does sat
desperately in front of television sets
watching the bit of drama of the next
four days in washington daniel patrick
moynihan the Assistant Secretary of
Labor said I don't think there's any
point in being Irish if you don't know
that the world is going to break your
heart
eventually I guess that we thought we
had a little more time merry McGrory
said to me they will never laugh again
and I said heavens Mary will laugh again
it's the just that will never be young
again in Washington grief was an agony
somehow the long hours past is the
new president took over with firmness
and strength but the role of the drums
when we walked to st. Matthew's
Cathedral on the frosty Monday will
sound forever in my ears and the wildly
twittering birds during the internment
at Arlington
while the statements of the world look
on it was also grotesque and so
incredible and just to footnote every
one of those people that often discussed
were friends of Catherine's grams and
our last reader as indeed Michael
Beschloss himself whose current
bestseller I am sure many of you have
already read or will soon be reading he
was very close to Kay and just
parenthetically I want to mention
another name that was mentioned earlier
which is the name of Meg Greenfield who
was so close to Michael to Kay to Sally
and Ben and to me I knew her longest we
became friends at Cambridge in 1952 when
we were both there she should have been
up here tonight she would have kept a
tight rein on the proceeding he's let me
tell you anyway Michael
she sure would Evan I think I hear my
voice in my ear and I'm gonna keep it
very brief since I do yes exactly
I'm brief you'll understand where this
comes from I thought I'd begin by saying
a very brief word about the author
before I read a piece from her book and
that is that if you were writing a
history of Washington in the 20th
century probably at its center would be
Kay Graham because if you think about it
she came here during the Herbert Hoover
administration she would loathe my
saying this because it makes her sound
like much more of a fossil than she ever
was during her lifetime but that's when
she came here with her parents and she
left this earth exactly just about
exactly eight weeks before 9/11 and if
you just imagine the kind of period of
time in Washington's life that she saw
and observed and to forgive me I was
Woodrow Wilson I meant to say instead of
Herbert Hoover I think she'd even loathe
hearing that even more Bob I think in
Kay's honor maybe we should just say
Herbert Hoover and leave it at that
in any case she met or knew most of
those presidents and I think the other
thing is that especially if you look at
the later years what we like about
Washington so much of it depended on the
fact that she was a woman of such
enormous talent and character not only
the great institution that she helped to
build the Washington Post Company in the
Washington Post itself but also the kind
of human beings she was I mean Ben and
Sally and I have talked about this a lot
and that is that Kate made everyone I
think behave a little bit better than
they normally would because of the kind
of example that she set when she gave a
dinner or if she had another event that
she helped to sponsor she could bring
together groups in Washington that in
many other cases people who were
normally not even talking to one another
they would suspend the antagonisms
because of the kind of person that she
was she really loomed above all this and
the other thing is the autobiography
that she wrote that small had so much to
do with and Bob Gottlieb which is
brilliant I think probably everyone here
has read it I suggest you buy it again
and read it once more
personal history and that is that it
took her life which was this wonderful
accomplished life of a wonderful person
and it made it a universal life not just
a life of someone who came into a great
company and a great newspaper at the
center of an important city but someone
who faced a lot of difficulties that
people did not know about until she
wrote this book and the moment that
really said this to me I was in Chicago
once I'd given a speech and a 22 year
old african-american woman came up to me
afterwards and said you come from
Washington don't you and I said yes I do
she said do you know Catherine Graham
and I said yes I do and she looked at me
as if I had touched a sacred biblical
treasure I mean she couldn't believe it
and that the thing was that she had read
that book and it spoke to her and she
said that it really inspired her a lot
and helped her to get through some of
the difficulties in her own life that's
what an achievement that book was anyway
what I thought I would read very briefly
in deference to Meg is a piece that's in
the book by Harry Truman on his becoming
president after Franklin Roosevelt's
death and it says so much for the way
that this book was done because the
normal temptation would have been to
take a section from Truman's own
autobiography on this event and if you
go to that section you will notice that
it was obviously not written by him and
it is so leaden that you can barely plot
through it what K does in this book is
she has Truman talking about his
accession to the presidency in his
retirement from an oral history and it
really is his voice I'm going to resist
the temptation to do my Truman imitation
but I don't need to because it's so much
like the voices in this book you hear
people talking about their lives in this
city he begins by saying all at once on
that terrible spring day in 1945
Franklin Roosevelt wasn't with us any
longer and suddenly I was President of
the United States Sam Rayburn the
Speaker of the House had asked me to
come over to his Capitol office that
afternoon and discuss some bills and
when I got there Sam was sitting and
talking with two other men
Sam started to mix some drinks and then
mentioned almost as an afterthought that
Steve early the president's press
secretary president roosevelt's had
called and asked that I call him as soon
as I got there Sam obviously didn't
think it was anything important and
neither did I but I returned the call of
course and Steve told me
please come over here to the White House
as quickly and quietly as you can
I went over immediately stopping only to
get my hat and tell one of my
secretaries where I was going and I
walked out to my car and driver so
quickly that the Secret Service didn't
know where I was and spent some frenzied
minutes to catching up with me but I
still didn't have the faintest guess of
what had happened and I wrote to my
mother and my sister Mary a few days
later I thought that the president had
come back to Washington to attend the
funeral of the Episcopal bishop who was
his good friend but then I was taken up
to Eleanor Roosevelt study in the White
House I knew from the look on her and
other faces what had happened even
before she put her hand on my shoulder
and said Harry the president is dead I
asked her is there anything I can do for
you her answer was is there anything we
can do for you you because you're the
one in trouble now you see this is
really Truman speaking just the day
before I joked about being vice
president when I addressed a group
covering the Senate of newspaperman one
of them called me mr. vice president and
I said smile when you say that I told
them if the Senate was the greatest
place in the world and that I wished I
were still a senator he said I was
getting along fine until I stuck my neck
out too far and got too famous then they
made me VP and now I can't do anything
now that I was president I won't deny
that at first I felt plenty of fear
myself at the added and overwhelming
responsibilities I tried to deal with it
lightly I told mrs. Truman that I
thought I'd make a good president
because Abraham Lincoln and I had so
much in common
she looked hard at me wondering when I
was turning pompous in my old age I
quickly told her that I wasn't comparing
myself to Lincoln in terms of
intelligence or administrative ability
but at least I said lakyn and I had
three other things in common
first of all I said Lincoln and I were
alike and that we both didn't like to
hunt and didn't like to fish he didn't
like to kill anything and I didn't like
to kill anything either second I said I
think Lincoln and I both had a sense of
humor and I told mrs. Truman a sense of
humor as a tremendous help to any man in
a position of authority because when a
stuffed shirt tries to tell a man in a
place of responsibility what he ought to
do the best way to settle the argument
is to stick a pin in him and let the
wind out and if you have a sense of
humor you'll have a good time doing it
third I said Lincoln and I both went
broke in business Lincoln's partner went
broke in business and Lincoln ended up
having owing $1,100 Lincoln also didn't
mind the store because he was always
lying behind the notions counter reading
newspapers and books to keep himself
informed well my old partner Eddie
Jacobson said that when our business was
going broke customers would come in all
right but I was always in a corner
reading about Andrew Jackson so now
there I was it was 709 p.m. on the
evening of 11th of April 12 1945 the
Chief Justice swore me in as president
of the United States in the Cabinet Room
underneath a portrait of Woodrow Wilson
and as I've already admitted I was
plenty scared but scared or not and
prepared or not I promised myself one
thing might evening and in the days and
nights that followed I promised myself
that I'd work damn hard and try damn
hard to be a good president
megha smiling and last we have our
mystery guest mystery guest look up
please see mystery guest the most famous
cop in Washington Donald Graham I am NOT
going to read anything from my mom's
book I want to say a word or two about
my fellow speakers and then thinking
over what I can do best here I am going
to moderate the question period and
decide which of our speakers is is best
qualified to answer your questions I
order two if you haven't read Michael
Beschloss s new book the conquerors
you're missing just about the best
history book this year and if you're
interested in what he said about
Roosevelt and Truman you'll find a lot
more in this wonderful book everything
my mother said about Benjy in personal
history is grossly understated and what
she said to me about Sally goes back to
the year I came to the Washington Post
and for both our sakes I won't say when
that was but she started telling me
about this new reporter in the Style
section who was gonna write things
nobody had ever written about Washington
DC as usual boy was she right Gottlieb
and EV were more than editor and
researcher to my mother knowing what the
editing of many books is like today I
cannot describe to you the good fortune
of someone who trips across god leave as
their editor and m'avez write that the
the conviction that he was the right
editor for her came from Meg who started
telling me about her relationship with
Bob by saying that they were fellow
students in
Umbridge England his graduate students
in the 1950s Bob Meg was there as a
young Smith graduate bob was there with
a wife and child but she said she first
met him when I think you were on a
viewer in a bike and she was in a car
and at a stoplight they fell to talking
about
yeah the metaphysical poet's that's how
peg described it and they rode down the
street together continuing to talk about
17th century verse as and you know she
recommended Bob as editor dove my mother
and my mother fortunately described in
personal history the huge difference -
it made to her writing of this book and
her pleasure in the book have likewise
my mom described the highly unusual role
I have played and I witnessed this
firsthand in personal history
ev was along on every interview of the
hundreds of interviews my mother did she
did interviews with people who went to
nursery school with her and have small
pulled together all of the transcripts
brought them made it so that the cogent
C of the information was always to hand
and that the if you liked that book its
success my mother where she here would
say that its successes owed in great
part to these two people and that's most
certainly true of Katharine Graham's
Washington Michael it is true that she
moved her family moved here in 1917 I
once asked her what was the first time
she met a president and she said it was
when they were taken to the White House
to say goodbye to the Coolidge's so I
have nominated myself to moderate your
question period you have been an
extremely patient audio
and I I feel horrified at the discomfort
some of you are suffering sitting on the
floor or leaning against the bookcases
and who would like to start any of the
writers comment on what has changed in
Washington would any of our panelists
like to comment on what has changed the
most in Washington Benji this is
especially true if you worked at The
Washington Post can everybody hear him
it is so large instead of damn big what
I I can remember the Washington Post
especially I have only been working at
the Washington Post's parts of six
decades not eight and I can remember
when when I was hired the person who had
to agree to hire me at 80 bucks a week
was Phil Gramm that's four grand a year
otherwise he may have wanted to save the
$4,000 to keep the paper afloat now that
is a true story and the paper lost a
million bucks a year and it had this
mercurial man that was so charming and
debonair and smart that it took your
breath away but they were broke all the
time if you to hire anybody you had to
go through an incredible part about it
at one time you never saw a Catherine
there or I never did and then all of a
sudden through a series of brilliant
maneuvers the post
and including a lot of good reporting
and good writing the post bit instead of
being the third newspaper in town was
the second newspaper in town and then
all of a sudden when the noise family
wasn't looking it was the first
newspaper in town still wasn't making a
hell of a lot of money but it did and
that is such a change when when you
think now that there are I learned from
Don Graham the other day and they
although he'd withheld us from me there
were eight hundred and thirty people in
the newsroom no you hired most of them
no I didn't do it it was 350 when I got
you can conned us out of all those slots
Michael what's you've been researching
the Washington of the Johnson ear or the
Washington of the Roosevelt era what's
what's what what has changed the most
palpably I think it was on a human scale
when Kay came here and for a long time
afterwards senators from both sides of
the aisle were here a good part of the
year because they did not have to run
home every weekend and they didn't have
to be on TV and I did not have to raise
money and raise money and raise money
and the result was that even though they
may have disagreed an awful lot about
politics they were usually pretty good
friends and could talk out those
differences sometimes very enjoyably as
in the famous case of someone like LBJ
and Everett Dirksen who used to do this
overburden bourbon and you can hear
these conversations and read accounts of
them it's just like someone you know
batting a badminton [ __ ] over the
shuttlecock over the net and then
Dirksen bats it back and they enjoyed
resolving these differences in
horse-trading
and it was also a time where I think if
you went to a dinner in Washington
Senators would fall down drunk and say
things that were indiscreet and a lot of
this maybe was not great for the public
interest but absolutely fascinating for
journalists and later historians when we
discussed this later on you're saying
senators don't fall down drunk today
never hasn't happened in 30 years
Sall you've written a couple of pieces
about the degree of partisanship in
Washington and whether that in fact is
something that there is a perception
that that has changed that the the
hostility between Democrats and
Republicans is greater than it was but
what did you find out in looking into it
Michael I agree with Michael and what
Michael just said is absolutely true and
and there are a number of reasons why I
one of the people I interviewed said the
the worst thing that ever happened to
Washington was the invention of the
airplane because what that meant was
that congressmen and Senators left town
on the weekends and they didn't hang
around here where they could actually go
to dinner and and see each other and
meet each other right now you've got a
situation where the people in Congress
go home
on Thursdays and come back on Mondays
and then they work 18 hours a day you
know they have power breakfasts and then
they and then they work until 10:00 or
11:00 at night and then they leave town
the women work and so they don't
entertain anymore so that you don't have
these evenings and where people can
actually on both sides of the aisle get
together parents are much more
interested in being good parents and
staying home with their children in the
old days they had nannies and they would
leave them and they'd go out and that
would be at the end of it so what you've
got is a situation now where people
don't know each other on it as Michael
said on a human level and so you don't
have the kind of sympathy I think Alan
Simpson was the former senator from
Wyoming was in Wyoming
yeah-hoo-hoo was one of the sort of the
last of the great going goer routers and
and he used to say you know I learned so
much every time I go out and when I'd
meet new people and when I'd see people
on opposite sides of the aisle when I'd
sit down to dinner you sit down at a
dinner or meet somebody at a cocktail
party or wherever and it's somebody who
you find out that you both have a sick
child or you have a parent who's in
trouble or you have something in common
with that person and that just doesn't
exist anymore and so what you have now
is a situation where there's an awful
lot of hostage
hostility and animosity and it really
comes from people not knowing each other
and therefore not being able to
sympathize with each other on a human
level well I think you're all doing very
well so far you had a hand up was
interested in mr. Bradley's reading
about Kennedy and that era and I
remember reading your conversations with
Kennedy book that I enjoyed so much
bless you but I just recently read the
article in the Atlantic about Kennedy's
medical history that's now just coming
out and I just wondered from your
perspective did you have any idea the
extent of his difficulties and do you
think it would be possible now in his
different atmosphere would something
like that be filled or to repeat for
anyone who didn't hear the question the
questioner oh I will say in Bradley's
behalf liked Ben's earlier book
conversations with Kennedy still
available to a limited but but read the
recent piece in the Atlantic on
Kennedy's health problems and wonders if
that should have been made known to the
public and if such a thing could be
concealed today I doubted it I doubt
that it could be concealed today because
ever since the details of Pike's
operations were that I think those were
the first presidential operations that
were made sort of a exhaustive
exhaustively public and Lyndon Johnson
pointing to his Gophers gallbladder it's
hard I knew about I knew more about
Kennedy's health then and I think there
was a lot out there
Addison's disease in those days was
known as an adrenal insufficiency and
nobody knew what the hell an adrenal
insufficiency was but and I think
everybody knew about his back pains
those incredible Janet
travell had this machine that mean a
needle that she pointed pushed into his
back big enough to inoculate a horse and
put it in there and worked around
squirting novocaine into it and I think
that was a fairly well known the you
know he was in the hospital just before
he was married he was in the hospital
just after he was married all of that
was pretty well covered of course where
it wasn't covered were the were the
affairs and I have trouble pleading
innocence to that except that all I can
tell you is that I saw him I described
151 conversations with him and most of
them were either on the telephone where
you certainly wouldn't come up or with
my wife at that time and and his wife
and him and it is not a subject that
comes up in those little conversations
what does the panel think of the changes
that have taken place in Washington
since the Home Rule government took
place in the early 70s so I feel like
this should be music you can refer it to
Ben if you want well we don't have Home
Rule actually not totally anyway it
seems to me that we've we've we now have
a mayor who is trying very hard to I
would think make the city more of an a
national city but in an international
City it seemed to me in the beginning
that I think Walter Washington was very
much just concerned about making by
taking care of Washington itself and and
making sure that they were there there
appeared to be some kind of
representation trying to bring business
in and establish this as a as a city
that was favorable to business and that
economically would be worthwhile
investing in and then we had some bad
years with Marion Barry but I get the
sense that we are now viewed even though
we don't have a contrail congressman and
real senator we're now viewed as a
viable City I mean just the mere fact
that we were considered for the Olympics
and I think that despite a lot of his
problems Tony Williams is responsible
for that but I think people around the
country see Washington as more of a real
city and not that place that you you
know you're probably scared to go to
because you don't know about the crime
and and all that so I just think it's
more of a perception that that we're
coming into our own and and when you
when you hear people talk about
Washington not as the capital but as an
American city they usually use it they
usually talk about it in the same breath
as they do New York and San Francisco
and LA and Chicago and Houston in 69 and
70 just before home rule I was a police
officer and the metropolitan Police
Department so I had ups an ex-government
servants insight into the city
government then it's changed a lot I
mean there's sounds right you know
they're the home rule powers are
certainly limited but I'm here to tell
you it's it's with our elected
government we're in a very different
position than we were so many years ago
next Michael just to state the obvious
Ben and I were just saying when Kay
Graham came to Washington this was a
very rigidly segregated City sure and if
you went back to the Washington of
Woodrow Wilson or Calvin Coolidge when
she was wishing the Coolidge is goodbye
it was a big symbol of the difference
between the promise of America and the
reality because here you have a
beautiful monuments in Washington which
was and supposed to be sort of the
earthly example of what America could be
and at the same time black people had to
sit in different parts of movie theaters
and the same things with restaurants
until very late in the 20th century
public schools and absolutely public
schools and you know for younger people
especially they see this is so
inevitable they can't believe that
within the lifetimes of many people now
living that people went through this the
other thing on a lighter note Benton
been mentioned LBJ showing his
gallbladder scar and Kay Graham had this
long very complex relationship with
Lyndon Johnson which foundered when she
began to be skeptical of the war in
Vietnam when LBJ showed his gallbladder
scar it was said that many people were
grateful that he had not had hemorrhoid
surgery
yes sir came here during Coolidge to be
near my mother so and if you have a lot
of individual memories much of which
you're touched on in the book but I
wonder if the top of the head if the
panelists would just say what right off
the top here and what is one's very
strong memory you have whether it's the
Kennedy assassination or whatever it is
well the question is for the panel
what's one very strong memory you have
of this city EV well I'll go with my
most recent strong memory of this city
and that comes from this afternoon when
Bob and I were wandering around I
decided that as a New Yorker he needed
to see some more of this city and not
just in the page of the book so we went
to the Library of Congress and then we
went to the Folger and we were sitting
in sort of a little alcove off to the
side and just started talking and we
were talking and talking and finally I
said maybe we should it was about ten
after four quarter after four I said
well you know let's go and take a look
at the theater and then we'll go out
well turn out the Folger closed at four
o'clock so we were very nearly trapped
in the Folger wondering how we were
gonna get out of there but but I think
as a memory of the city I think that
that anything that the city is very real
to me as well and and accessible and but
that's one that I will remember all
three
you don't me are you indeed you are with
me right now as always I Michael
reminded me when he was talking about
what a segregated City it was that I'm
an army brat and I lived at Fort Myer
and Virginia Frome I we had my father
headquarters at Fort Myer we lived on
the parade ground and I when Martin
Luther King came to town and there was
this huge gathering on the mall my my
step-grandmother not my favorite she was
the wicked step grandmother from
Savannah Georgia called and started
screaming at us to get out of town
because those African bullies were
invading the city and we had to leave
this horrible city also we were there
when Jack Kennedy was assassinated so I
do remember my brother and sister and I
walking down to the edge of Arlington
Cemetery and watching is what we could
see at the funeral from right in front
of our house because we lived right
there next to the chapel but one memory
is when we were at a party when you
mentioned the library the Library of
Congress one night there was some sort
of event been and Michael Beschloss and
I were there and Michael and I walked
over to the bar to get a drink and we
looked out it was sunset and we looked
out across Washington and there was the
Washington Monument we were you know the
Capitol the Lincoln Memorial we could
see the whole city and as the Sun was
setting on this city I just almost burst
into tears and I grabbed Michael I said
look at this city is this not the most
beautiful city in the whole world who
couldn't love this city do you remember
that moment right
oh that since I keep that moment keeps
coming back to me when I think of
Washington it's hard for me to do one
one moment but how about the riots of
1968 when the National Guard was
patrolling the streets and the rioters
got broke into stores about four blocks
from the White House three blocks from
the White House that wasn't I'll never
forget that if I live to be a hundred
I'll never forget the President Nixon's
farewell to Washington that after a long
period of waiting and wondering and I'll
never forget that but it happens it
seems to me when I sat down to write my
book that one of those events was
happening every two or three years well
one of my earliest memories of
Washington I came here when I was 16
years old to be an intern in the office
of a Democratic senator when I was in
high school they gave us the spring off
to come and live here and work in a
senator's office and during that spring
which was the spring of 1972 J Edgar
Hoover died and there was going to be a
memorial service in the Capitol Rotunda
and as I remember there were taken
tickets given perhaps one ticket per
senator for each senator to attend the
memorial service and the senators who
admired Hoover all went to the service
the Senators who did not did not and my
senator really detested Hoover and what
he had done with the FBI and civil
liberties so they decided that they
would give the ticket to the most junior
menial person in the office working the
Xerox machine in the back room which is
myself and so the result was at age 16 I
got to attend Jagger Hoover's funeral
well I think I've moderated enough it's
8 o'clock and you have been incredibly
patient and frankly some of you look
incredibly uncomfortable all right I
will volunteer to stay here and sign
books if anybody wants some signed since
the author is not available to 'evil Bob
will and I'll draft the rest of you if
if that is wanted thanks very much for
coming
Catherine grams Washington is published
by Knopf a division of Random House
visit Random House dot-com / can opt for
more information